вийшов шокуюч абсолютно матеріал який не
обговорюють ні в Марафоні на жаль дуже
де мало в українських медіа а він
викликає ну дуже важливий резонанс і я
би хотіла щоб ви про нього знали Отже
рахункова палата оперелюднила аудит
перевірки закупівель міністерством
оборони за перше півріччя 23го року і це
абсолютно шокуючий документ який
підтверджує що всі розслідування е
журналістів а пам'ятаєте як там офіс
президента позитивные блогеры банкової
слуги всі кричали що ці журналісти
брешуть про яйця по 17 Так ось тепер це
не журналісти розслідувачі не парохаботи
там не опозиція а офіційна структура яка
має Такі повноваження державні саме
контролювати моніторити перевіряти
проводити аудит витрачання бюджетних
коштів констатує про абсолютно
неефективни менеджмент Міністерства
оборони часів міністра резнікова от я
хочу зачитати просто кілька речей
да Отже рахункова палата вона
підтверджує інформацію про зловживання в
міністерстві оборони в першому півріччі
цього року Міністерство не забезпечило
обґрунтованого планування і використання
бюджетних коштів і
з фактично не здійснювало моніторинг цін
на продукти харчування і навіть після
скандалу коли вилізли оці от
журналістські розслідування про яйця по
17 і певні контракти були розірвані і
заключені нові все
одно продукти харчування тобто ті
продукція яка була закуплена
міністерством оборони Вона була десь на
третину дорожче закуплена ніж наприклад
службаю безпеки України чи Національної
гвардії і непродуктивно було витрачено 5
млрд грн із тих що витрачались
на забезпечення продуктами харчування
неекономне 6 млрд з порушеннями 630 млн
з порушеннями
процедур 9 млрд ну на складах застаріле
майно там знайдено і все це просто
говорить про
е дуже серйозні втрати які за оцінками
рахункової палати тільки за перше
півріччя і тільки на продуктах
харчування складають від х до 7 млрд грн
це ті Кошти які могли піти на Дрони на
артилерійські снаряди на техніку на все
необхідне сьогодні для армії тому що
збройні сили скаржиться на страшенний
дефіцит наприклад боєкомплекту і
артилерійських снарядів і все це можна
було закупити ну от ще кілька цифр
наприклад добова вартість харчування на
одного військовослужбовця надобув в
секторі безпеки оборони Да в СБУ це було
грн в Нацгвардії 118 грн а
в армії абсолютно інша була цифра і все
це було там просто завищені оці продукти
харчування на третину і аудитори також
сказали що з 409 найменувань продуктів
каталогу майже
75% не мали практичного застосування ну
тобто закуповувалися якихось своїх там
підрядників тільки аби
розтринькати кошти і очевидно що Ну мені
якось дивно що такий шокуючий матеріал
сьогодні не вивчається українськими
журналістами Я думаю ви мало про це
дебачили сьогодні інформації в Марафоні
про це Жодного слова от тільки на
кількох сайтах таких як цензур там або в
соцмережах вийшли так само матеріали
статті про цей аудит До речі наживалися
на закупівлях навіть Я не знаю там
харчів для службових собак це якийсь
мародерство під час війни І от Зверніть
увагу що немає жодної реакції
прем'єр-міністра і уряду хоча іде мова
про їх Міністерство і це ж не
Міністерство іншої країни немає жодної
реакції офісу президента і позитивних
блогерів які там на кожен чих опозиції а
Брут льють і гедоту пишуть а тут таке
мовчання і немає поки що реакції
антикорупційних структур хоча очевидно
що саме це є підстави для таких
серйозних розслідувань і антикорупційні
органи мають в першу чергу розслідувати
використання і зловживання бюджетні Тому
що це є державні кошти кошти платників
податків А ми обов'язково будемо
вимагати заслухати цей аудит в
парламенті і створювати тимчасову слідчу
комісію тому що такого щоби от люди
прийшли похазяйнували в міністерстві
потім собі пішли абсолютно безкарно
такого бути не може хочу нагадати що з
такими пафосом призначалося тоді міністр
і його заступники куди йшли там і
громадські активісти і антикорупціонери
і і всі І от ну бачимо такий дивний
результат
АА ну на це треба дати відповіді От і
дуже важливо щоби Міністерство оборони
нинішній його там керівний склад важно
ознайомилися з цим аудитом з цим звітом
І просто прийняли всі заходи для того
щоби з цими структурами ну які там
давали завищені ціни просто не було
більше підписано ніяких контрактів ну і
зараз розслідується інше шокуючи
абсолютно факти коли так само мільярди
гривень пішли на закупівлю начебто зброї
техніки в 22-му році але не були
здійснені ці поставки і зараз немає там
снарядів іншої техніки які були
закуплені і немає Ніхто за це не
відповідає Це ненормально і очевидно що
коли такі матеріали виходять від Е
офіційних структур то потім ми не можемо
дивуватися коли міжнародні медіа так
само пишуть про корупцію в Україні і
зловживання Я думаю що парламенту тут
варто Прокинутися так само згадати про
свою контролюючу функцію і до речі цей
звіт рахункової палати робився після
слухань в антикорупційному комітеті де і
наші депутати дуже активно якраз
працюють і
звичайно Важливо щоб от зараз ці
підсумки заслухалися не лише в комітеті
антикорупційному а зробимо все для того
щоб це слухання відбулося в сесійній
залі в парламенті і там мають бути
журналісти тому що ось цей марафон де
солодкою ватою готують українців і
розповідають як Все добре він просто так
само є однією з причин такої
безвідповідальності влади колип піра
роки навіть рік і вісім місяців думали
що за зачиненими дверима можна чудити що
завгодно і Ніхто про це не дізнається ну
бачимо що виходить ця правда вона чесно
кажучи шокуюча І влада повинна не
закривати на це очі і рота а робити
висновки а висновки очевидні покарання
винних реальна а не фасадна боротьба з
корупцією і зміна уряду де мають
працювати не лояльні не знаєте такі що
бояться слова сказати офісу а професійні
Я думаю що тільки так Україна може
вистаяти